I've heard that a lot of you guys have
been missing my intro so I thought that
I'd bring it back hey we love guys my
name is the churner
welcome to another video so today we're
going to be doing another one of these
kind of one hour challenge things last
time I did this I made a game in an hour
check out that video if you haven't
already basically what I did is this guy
called Danny made a game in an hour
using unity and I thought I would try
and recreate that same exact game but
using my engine inside hazal which is a
very difficult task because hazel is
like barely an engines barely capable of
doing well anything but nevertheless I
ended up making like exactly the same
game and it took me around two hours or
so and one of the hardest things to do
in that challenge was all of the
particles because hazel doesn't have a
particle system in fact doesn't have
like the rendering technology we
typically use to render particles and so
because of that I have to ride a
particle system from scratch within that
time limit and I know that a lot of you
were interested in how exactly I managed
to pull that off and honestly speaking I
don't think particle systems are that
difficult especially like the one that
was needed for this game where it was
just a bunch of colored squares it
wasn't like some kind of photo realistic
textured you know blending like smoke or
something like that it was a lot easier
than that it was just a bunch of colored
squares with like a lifetime and all of
that stuff not that difficult to do so
what I thought I would do in today's
video is basically set up another timer
and see if I could write a particle
system from scratch within an hour and
I'm actually not gonna use hazel at all
for this video I'm just going to use my
OpenGL base library if you guys don't
know what I'm talking about check out
that video there basically I just made
like an OpenGL kind of core based
library that would easily let me just
write OpenGL card on top of an already
existing project so that's the plan for
today we're gonna see if we can write a
part of the system from scratch within
an hour but first I want to thank surf
shark for sponsoring this video
surf shark is a fantastic VPN service
that makes online privacy protection
easy and attainable it encrypts
all Internet traffic sent to and from
all of your devices and keeps your IP
address hidden so the
no one can see what you're doing online
and speaking of devices Surf Shack has
no limit to how many devices you can use
it on simultaneously which is great
these days we spend a lot of time online
almost as much as we do sleeping and
because of that the internet knows a lot
about us but by using surf shark all of
your data is sent through a secure VPN
tunnel so that no one can see it without
your permission surf shop is more than
just a VPN though it's more of like a
fully fledged security toolset and
because of that has a lot of other great
features for example Surf Shack also
blocks ads which is great because I tend
to travel quite a lot and not have that
much mobile data and by blocking ads I
save a bunch of mobile data and also my
browsing experience is just faster and
speaking of ads have you ever been
spooked by how an ad just seems to know
exactly what you've been talking about
that's because your data is out there
but not with surf shop surf shark have
been amazing enough to give you guys 83%
off and one free month all you have to
do is sign up using the link in the
description below and use the code
Cherno go ahead and sign up now using my
code and make sure that you put on all
of your devices so that you're
completely protected all right let's
write this particle system so for this
video instead of just showing you guys
like a time-lapse of me working on this
thing and then later adding some
voiceover which let's be honest can be
faked anyway I thought that I would
instead just take you through the
completed code and explain a little bit
more about how it actually works I don't
want to spend too long going through all
this over there something that I've
missed that you guys want to know just
leave comment below and I'll try and
just reply to that comment or make
another video or something like that and
without further ado let's get into this
so we have this class called particle
system and that's kind of it you know
there's just this simple sauce file this
header file that basically makes up the
entire particle system the only
additional file that is necessary for
this particle system or additional class
I should say is this random class and
this is exactly the same random class as
the one that appeared in that one hour
game that I made in hazel and it's it's
super simple again something that you
would definitely expect to be part of
the engine it's just using this kind of
C++ standard library random like
distribution function and random number
generation algorithm here and we're just
setting up a static instance of that and
then there's just like this helper
function here called static float float
and and that basically just returns a
number between 0 and 1 so it just
samples this random distribution here
and then divides it by the highest
possible number that will result from
this function here so basically it gives
us a number between 0 and 1 and that's
great because it just makes it super
easy I love doing stuff like this
because it makes it super easy to
generate any random number I want for
example if I want something that's
between like I don't know 0 and 10 I can
just call you know this random float
function and then multiply it by 10 and
then obviously I'll get something
between 0 and 10 if I want something
between 1 and 0 obviously I don't need
to multiply it with anything if I want
something between 1 and a thousand you
guys get the point it's really easy to
just kind of whack that on and I to be
honest I kind of prefer that to
functions with parameters where it's
like okay specify your range or
something like that all right that's the
random class now if I spend too much
time here because it's super simple and
should make sense particle system is the
meat of everything so again you can see
it's very simple we have an on update
function we have a render function and
we have this emit function so emit will
actually emit a particle just one
particle and the settings that it uses
to actually emit this or rather I should
say the parameters that it uses are
these particle props which stands for
particle properties so the reason that
I've made this struct in the first place
is because I don't want to have you know
one two three four five six seven eight
nine parameters all over here inside
these function parameters that's just
way too much it's gonna be really hard
to set and also it means that by taking
in a struct like this I can not only
have defaults such as this like 1.0 F
obviously you can do that with function
arguments as well but it's a little bit
more complicated just because like you
there have to be at the end of the
function whereas here I could you know
set a default position or whatever I
want but also it's really useful because
I can reuse these same particle props to
emit particles that are
that should be pretty much the same so
when I'm when I'm emitting smoke it's
nice to have a little template and maybe
only the position changes but everything
else stays is saying maybe the velocity
will change as well that's what I did in
that 1 hour game because obviously the
ship the ship's Direction kind of
controlled the velocity of the actual
particles in which direction they would
move in but other than that just by
having this particle props here is
really cool because I can just kind of
create an instance of this struct
somewhere inside my client code and then
I can just change only the parameter I'm
interested in changing and just keep
passing that into that this emit
function to emit more and more particles
as you'll see in a minute alright so
other than that we have this struct
called particle this is what a particle
currently is this is what makes up a
particle so a particle at any given
frame will have a position of velocity a
begin and end color a rotation a
beginning end size lifetime life
remaining and whether or not it's active
because this ties in and this active
boolean really ties in with this
particle pool because what we want to do
is create a pool of particles it what
you don't want to do is every time you
need a new particle create a new
particle because by doing that it's just
gonna dramatically slow down everything
that's going on what we want to do is
basically pre-allocate this pool of
particles and then continually reuse
that array that way there's no memory
allocation everything's kind of
contiguous in memory and I mean it's
just gonna perform a lot faster we have
this pool index which is basically the
index of the currently active particle
now or rather the next the next active
particle so the next particle I should
say that will be active once we actually
emit it so what we do interesting lis
here as we start at the maximum size if
I go over it as if to the C++ code
you'll see here that the particle pool
has a size of 1000 particles so
obviously because this is like you know
running in our it's hot card it to be 9
and 9 here because that's the last
possible index and the reason we start
at index 9 and 9 and all 0 is just
because when we render this we should be
rendering it in reverse order so that
everything can blend together properly
especially when we start dropping those
alpha values if you don't do it that way
then it's just you'll get artifacting
we're basically weren't blended
correctly with anything because it
doesn't know how to alright anyway so
and then we just have some basic stuff
here to actually render the particles so
because I'm not using any kind of engine
here I'm just using this OpenGL library
that I've made we have to do all of the
OpenGL rendering ourselves which is fine
and there's not that much to do but we
basically need to have these things here
ok cool let's dive into this obviously
an update is a function that will be
called every frame as will on render so
on render just takes in a camera whereas
on update is what does the actual I
guess particle simulation and that's why
it takes in a time step ok into the C++
code so again in the beginning we just
resize this particle pool to be 1000
particles so this is not like reserved
or anything it's resize it will actually
instantiate 1000 particles which is
really nice because again we already
have done that there's no nothing that
needs to be done when a particle gets
emitted it's all kind of pre allocated
pre pre instantiated and then in the on
update particle actually let's look at
an image first probably because I think
that'll make more sense and I've got
some weird like errors here I don't know
if I accidentally press something I
don't think I did I mean I did that but
no I don't know it's probably just it's
probably just nothing yeah it is nothing
it's just Visual Studio so what does it
mid-to well em it's job is to actually
create a particle but the particle
already exists it just needs to
basically reuse or recycle an existing
particle in memory so what it does is it
queries basically be the active pool
index which is where are we up to in
this particle pool what is the next
index we can use and then inside that
particle pool using that particle index
it retrieves a reference to a particle
so this is now basically a blob of
memory that represents this new particle
we're emitting step one is to make it
active so that it will get rendered and
updated and then we can basically fill
out the rest based on the particle
properties that get specified so again
really simple stuff position obviously
just sets to position rotation is kind
of hard coded here you can't customize
it through particle props
this was basically the same as that one
our game as I mentioned and I did not
care about rotation I just wanted it to
rotate I didn't care about the rate I
could just hard code that you can see
this is an example of using that random
float function then we have the velocity
which again is just completely random
here the velocity variation controls how
big we we can vary our velocity so you
can see we kind of start with a base
velocity and then we add on to that and
number that kind of by default will be a
number between negative 0.5 and positive
0.5 and then that will get multiplied
with whatever the variation here so in
other words if we say that the variation
is 2 meaning we can kind of go within 2
within 2 units or 1 unit either side of
0 right we can add that on here then
that's what it will do so in other words
if I actually specify a horizontal
velocity variation of 2 and then an
initial velocity of 1 what that means is
that since I'm going to add that on I'm
gonna get a final velocity somewhere
between 0 and 2 because it's going to
add on 1 or subtract 1 else any number
between that range from that kind of
base velocity and you can do that kind
of separately on each axis which is
really nice because you can use it to
simulate gravity so in other words if I
have a velocity variation I can I can
make that velocity Y be always negative
because it has to be negative
potentially because I always want the
particles to go down maybe just a
different rates color begin color and
super simple this is just the color over
life this is the lifetime we also have
to keep track of life remaining because
according to the life remaining that's
what we actually well life time is the
total lifetime but we also keep track of
life remaining so that we can actually
figure out the percentage of life that
has passed and we need that so that we
can properly figure out you know any
kind of looping I guess functionality so
anything that needs to linearly be
interpolated over the over life such as
the color or like the Alpha as well all
the size anything that has a beginning
end we need this so that we can figure
out at what kind of stage of its life
that particle is at size begin size end
again with the variation thing super
simple again and then we have pool index
so we decrement this
and then we mod it by the size so that
it wraps around $2.99 again if it needs
to and this will basically the the
purpose of this I guess is just to set
up the pool index for the next particles
that when we omit the next particle we
know the index in memory where we can
actually write particle data to okay
cool
super simple on update this goes through
the entire particle pool if it's not
active it continues now it could
potentially be safe to just break at a
certain point the reason being that we
know that if a particle is not active if
it suddenly hears something that's not
active it's likely that the all the
further ones will also be inactive
however this requires you to know the
particle this starting particle index
because if you picture the particle pool
as like a little window in memory that
keeps moving and in fact as I'm saying
this I'm realizing that there's so much
to explain here and not much time so
maybe I'll make another video with like
diagrams and stuff but let me know if
you want to see that in the comment
section below but basically because of
that we need to know the starting index
if we want to break so this is just a
lot easier obviously to do and a lot
safer so if the particle is life is gone
it's dead then we can just set active to
false and continue to the next particle
otherwise very simple what we do an on
update we just subtract the life
remaining by the time step because the
life remaining is in seconds and the
life that you specify for a particle is
in seconds so if I set the live to 1.0
as it is by default that's one second
position and rotation obviously we
increment the position by the velocity
times the time step and then the
rotation as well by a hard-coded 0.01
which is in radians multiplied by the
time step all right
rendering now this is a really simple
hack here I have a little if not M quad
VA which basically means if the quad
vertex array which is this is that a
zero means we haven't created the vertex
array yet so we'll go ahead and do all
of our initialization code I didn't want
to do this here because the particle
system is meant to be used as a stack
based variable which means they can
definitely be initialized before or
instantiated before OpenGL has been
instantiated which means we can't do all
this stuff up in jail been initialized
initialized instantiated you guys get
the point but so I couldn't put the
stuff in the constructor and I really
did not want to write an init function
so this is just a nice easy way to be
like okay well before you ran delicious
make sure that you can render I'm not
going to go through this stuff it's
really basic rendering code this creates
a quad that's it it creates a quad and
it retrieves uniform locations so
uniforms like the view projection the
transform and the color that that's it
it's super simple nothing to talk about
Apple so we use program and this is
again uploading the camera matrix to
that particle shader which we might look
at in a second and then the particle
pool so this goes through the particle
pool and again what we've done is and
this is the cool thing here we've when
we emit a particle we go through a
backwards like this so we can actually
go through everything forwards which is
technically better because I don't think
I like when we might not be like
particles could get emitted quite often
per frame but we're definitely not going
through the whole pool to emit particles
whereas to update and surrender we
definitely have to go through that
entire particle pool which means that I
don't want to go backwards because that
wouldn't be very good for the memory
access or anything like that so we can
still go through everything forwards
which is great it's just that they get
emitted from the end which again if you
don't have a screen full of particles
might be a little bit not good because
it has to continue past a whole bunch in
fact that's another reason why I said
you have to know the starting particle
if you want to break okay fade away
particles so here all we do is we look
between the color end and the color
begin right so that we figure out what
based on the remaining life what the
color should be and then we also
multiply the Alpha by life so life will
be a value between zero and one because
we're dividing it by the total lifetime
the current lifetime by the total
lifetime and then this will basically
make it so that it just fades out to
zero alpha by the end of its life
linearly ok flirt size again loping
between size and the size begin based on
the life same with no that's it that's a
little lapping and then rendering
obviously all we do is just create a
transformation matrix here with the
position the rotation
and the scale because obviously size is
also something we care about then we
upload those uniform matrices and this
is what one year for matrix which is the
transform and then also the color and
the color just avec for and then we
render one single particle now obviously
this is not efficient because you would
want to render all of the particles in
one drakul very likely like literally
all of them definitely I think and well
in this case is only a thousand marks
they're definitely all of them in one
drakul whereas we're not doing that and
again that's just because the one hour
kind of time constraint and also because
it is based on that one hour game and
hazel did not support batching at all
there is currently a batch rendering
OpenGL series going on on my channel
definitely check that out I'll have it
linked in the in the top right corner
that's gonna that's basically the
technique I'm talking about where we
actually batch everything together into
a single drawer call instead of
rendering all these particles separately
because that's a lot slower and that
will definitely limit just how many
particles we can have on the screen at
once because if we use up at this entire
particle pool that's 1000 particles 1000
drawers which is already kind of getting
up there okay that's it I think that's
it
now the shader the shade is not that
interesting it's just a this is just a
normal vertex shader nothing special at
all and the colleges and the color
traders also special surprise I mean not
special it's just literally setting the
output color to be that uniform color
that we specify so super simple stuff
and then be really simple
I guess sandbox layer that I wrote which
is again really simple as you can see
all that does is enable blending which
is really important because we want to
be able to fade the particles out and we
need them to blend with each other
properly
and with the clear color as well this is
what I was talking about and how good it
is to initialize this kind of particle
prop so rather to kind of have this
particle prop system because I can just
set up all this stuff here and again you
know the color the color begin and end
of each particle that I generate it's
gonna be the same so why would I keep
setting that you know all the time I can
just kind of store it here and then if I
want to actually emit a particle I can
just do particle system in it and then
yeah just setting this stuff up again
you can tweak it however you
you can expose it to GUI and play around
with it if you like as well this is just
me making sure that we can resize if we
resize the window jail viewport will be
resized as well and then on update
clears the color and then if the left
mouse button is pressed what we do is we
basically so most of this code is not
actually most of this code is to figure
out the particle position the reason is
we have a camera we can move the camera
around we can zoom in and out and we can
resize the window and so because of all
these floating parameters and because we
can literally move the camera as well we
want and we want to well the example
I've gone with is when you click it it
emits particles at your mouse cursor
because of that I obviously need to have
all this code to figure out where in the
wind world space
I should be emitting the particles um
and then that's it and then what I do is
I emit five of them at once because why
not just make it a little bit more
particles and more fun and also because
they obviously have velocity variations
size variations all that stuff so if you
omit five particles they'll all be a
little bit different but they will
originate at the same position with the
same color and all that stuff cool then
I just update the particle system once
per frame and render it once per frame
that's it and I've added some I am GUI
controls because why not so we can
customize the birth colour death color
and the life time and of course feel
free to play around with that however
you like okay and with all of that said
let's launch this and take a look at
what I was able to do in under an hour
okay so here we have this kind of OpenGL
sandbox thing here if I click and drag
my mouse it will emit particles and I
can zoom out I can move the camera as
well so you can see I'm moving the
camera here yeah that's pretty much it
pretty cool right so we have all of
these particles being emitted from my
mouse cursor and then if I I'll try and
kind of fullscreen this so I'll resize
it to be the full screen that obviously
works and we can kind of have a little
that stuff here so let's play with the
lifetime for fun so you can turn this
way up so like this will be like you
know 13 seconds which as you can see is
quite a lot before it kind of fades out
and also I don't think I'm glocks the
controls but you can also make it really
short
so like 0.3
seconds which is kind of cool as well so
that's kind of customizing in a lifetime
I'll just take it back to like two or
something and then we have birth color
and death color so like I said the birth
college like Wyatt the death color to
black or something like that and now you
can see they kind of fade out to black
or I could make them fade out to like
pink or something like that whatever
you're into or we could even do
something more fun maybe by making it
kind of go maybe red to blue and that
way would kind of become purple before
it goes blue that's pretty cool so there
you go that's the particle system one
our really simple stuff and then you
also have like all the size variation
and stuff going on and obviously you can
add so much more to this but this was
just kind of a simple I guess example
and yeah looks pretty cool so that is
the particle system in one hour and of
course I'll have a download link for all
of this code in the description below
let me quickly see if I can just draw
like a little Chennai lager hey there it
is pretty cool honestly that was not all
that difficult and it took me 57 minutes
and I mean I added a whole bunch of
stuff in the end just because I had
extra time now obviously we are dealing
with a rather simple particle system
with plenty of limitations but the point
is something like a particle system is
super easy to just smash together like I
just did and it can just massively
improve the visual quality the visual
fidelity of your games or any kind of
graphics that you're working on not to
mention they're extremely fun like I'm
just gonna probably keep tinkering with
this for a while just cuz it's fun now I
mentioned several times that this is not
like an optimal way to write a particle
system and that's due to a number of
reasons in fact I might make a little
bit of a particle kind of miniseries let
me know if you want to see that in the
comment section below just explaining
how this kind of all works and how to
build it maybe step-by-step and how to
improve it over time but one of the
reasons there's no optimal is because
everything is rendered as a separate
drakul which is terrible I'm currently
doing a series on batch rendering check
that out if you haven't already that's
basically where we take all of these
squares and we've put them into one draw
call that massively improves the number
of particles we can actually have on the
screen at once because if I push this
too far it's just gonna start it's just
gonna take too much time and we're gonna
start losing frames the other reason is
just with how we process data and the
kind of for loops and just the layout
basically in memory it's not optimal for
CPU keishon or anything like that we
might talk about that later as well but
the point is it works and I want that to
be like a takeaway for a lot of people
people just tend to overcomplicate
software engineering for no apparent
reason maybe just to look cool or
something like that the simplest
solution is like always the best if you
can write something and it works and is
really simple them the more simple it is
the better because apart from other
people having to deal with it and also
you being able to move on with your life
instead of spending your whole life
redesigning this particle system to make
it the most complicated best thing ever
which probably won't be anyway it'll be
nice and simple and easy everyone will
understand it you'll be able to move on
and it will work so in other words what
I'm saying is that yes this is simple
and it does a lot of naive kind of what
other people would say are stupid things
but it works it works well it looks
great and it performs adequately so
there's no reason to over complicate
things for nothing anyway let me know
what you guys thought of this video if
you have any other kind of one-hour
challenges or maybe even 24 hour
challenges if that's something a little
bit more complicated let me know in the
comment section below because I really
love doing stuff like this it's a ton of
fun don't forget to check out surf shark
there's a link in the description below
that'll save you eighty-three percent
and also give you one month for free
make sure you use the code chatter make
sure you guys stay safe online and I
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]